e aí galera que assistir o canal tudo
com vocês um vídeo de hoje vai ser a
minha música nova e essa música eu fiz
uma pessoa que eu gosto muito e eu quero
que vocês me ajudem a fazer essa música
chegar até a pessoa então que você faz
você vai clicar no gosto e sei que vai
me ajudar demais a espalhar a música e
vai lá no twitter e poste hashtag
assista tão linda o enderson mundo que
vai ser a divulgação em massa então
vamos lá
[Música]
esse projeto me domina esse sorriso
melcin no seu jeito de menina que me faz
arrepiar madrugada são demais e diz me
satisfaz não sei lá onde me fascina
mesmo sem ter celular
eu vou me envolvendo eu vou dependendo
coração tá doendo então deixa de
besteira e deixa eu te amar
eu só quero saber como é que tá teu
coração que tiver bem eu fico sem mas se
ele não tiver benfica o chão que me faz
bem é você
então fique chateada quando eu pedi pra
ficar mais um pouco aqui no chat comigo
de madrugada
tudo isso porque eu quero te ver bem o
teu sorriso que me faz feliz
eu sei que eu não sou essas coisas mas
eu posso ser um cara que sempre quis
eu sei que eu sou só uma parte e outra
um boné para trás em qualidade aminta
fizesse a letra pra te alegrar quero
definir não quero chorar essa menina que
eu acho linda tão linda
esse teu jeito sereno e seu corpo moreno
esse teu olho pequeno que eu não consigo
parar de olhar linda tão linda a todos
querendo demais e eu não for a taís vaga
o mel cara e vou atrás até de onça pra
poder te dar
eu só quero
saber como é que tá teu coração que
estiver bem eu fico sem mas se ele não
tiver bem ficou no chão e me faz bem é
você
então fique chateada quando eu pedi pra
ficar mais um pouco aquém do chat comigo
de madrugada tudo isso porque eu quero
te ver bem o teu sorriso que me faz
feliz
eu sei que eu não sou essas coisas mas
eu posso ser o cara que sempre quis
eu sei que eu sou um rapaz que eu olho
pra trás em qualidade ainda fiz essa
letra prática legal quero ser feliz não
quero chorar essa menina que eu acho
linda tão linda a esse seu jeito sereno
e seu corpo moreno e seu olho pequeno
que me faz não querer mais parar de
olhar linda tão linda a todos que querem
de maggi eu não vou olhar pra trás vaga
o meu carro e vou atrás até de onça pra
poder tirar
olha o que existe até o final se você
tiver gostar por favor não esquece
daquele que usar a hashtag no twitter
assista tão linda o windows mundos redes
sociais é que a descrição está gratuito
e facebook tudo vem aí a nós falou